Okay. So, uh today we we are looking at
three major events in American history.
Uh the moon landing, the assassination
of JFK, and 911.
Now, as you may know, the official story
is something that a lot of people do not
accept.
Okay? So, we're going to look at the
official story and then we'll see some
of the issues
with the um official story. So, first I
want to show you some videos. First,
we're going to watch the moon landing.
So, 1969, July 20th, they shoot three
men into space. Uh Boss Uldren, Michael
Collins, Neil Armstrong. Neil Armstrong
becomes the first man in the world to
walk on the moon. Okay? And this is his
journey. All right? So, let's watch it
together.
>> What you will see is that it takes a lot
of thrust to get the man into space.
>> 30 ft down. 2 and 1/2. Picking up some
dust.
30 ft. Two and a half down. Break that
out.
Four forward.
Forward. Drifting to the right level.
>> This is considered the greatest
achievement in human history. It took
years and years of hard work involving
400,000 people are working for NASA to
accomplish this perfect landing on the
moon.
>> We're breathing again. Thanks a lot.
Okay, Neil, we can see you coming down
the ladder now.
I'm at the foot of the ladder. The lamb
footeds are only uh
>> What is amazing is that this is being
broadcast live from the moon back to
NASA. So, their technology back then is
far superior to to our technology today.
Small step for man,
one leap for mankind.
This is so great you can't believe it.
>> Oh, I believe it. Charlie,
>> get ready. John,
>> look at it. Would you
>> got all your steering and get straight?
>> Oh, this is going to be some kind of
different ride.
Hippity hippity hippity up and over
hill.
I know this looks fake, but it's not.
Okay, this is official NASA footage live
from the moon.
And this is the best part. Okay, the
best part is when they return from the
moon back to Earth. You see how easy it
is? It's just like they just fly up. No
resistance at all. Okay,
perfect.
Humanity's greatest achievement. Now,
what's amazing
is
that while they were on the moon,
>> both of you,
>> President Nixon and the astronauts had a
phone conversation.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, I think something rather important
is coming up here. Uh
>> Neil and Buzz.
This is being broadcast broadcast live
to American people. Okay. Would like to
say a few words to
[Music]
>> Hello Neil and Buzz. I'm talking to him
by telephone from the old
and this certainly has to be the most
historic telephone call ever made from
the White House. I just can't tell you
how proud we all are of what you have
done. For every American, this has to be
the proudest day of our lives. And for
people all over the world, I am sure
that they too join with Americans in
recognizing what an immense feat this
is. Because of what you have done, the
heavens have become a part of man's
world.
>> Okay? The heavens have become part of
man's world. Right? Remember how last
class we talked about how they wanted to
bring the heavens down to earth. Okay?
This is idea of inversion. Okay?
But do you see how amazing it is that
they were able to have this seamless
phone conversation?
Okay.
Okay. Now
they go to the moon and you would think
that they would come back and they're
heroes, right? Imagine if the school
took you all on a trip to Mount Everest.
You spent six months climbing the
world's tallest mountain. You come back
and you feel amazing, right? You feel on
top of the world. You're ecstatic. You
want the whole world to know about it.
Well, they should be feeling the same
thing, right?
>> Okay. Here's a press conference after
the uh
>> Sorry.
>> I have two brief questions I'd like to
ask if I may. When you were carrying out
that incredible moon walk, did you find
that the surface was equally firm
anywhere or were there harder and softer
spots that you could detect? And
secondly, when you looked up at the sky,
could you actually see the stars and the
solar corona in spite of the glare? We
were never able to see stars from the
lunar surface or on the daylight side of
the moon by eye without looking through
the optics. Uh I don't recall during the
period of time that we were
photographing the sonar what what stars
we could see.
>> I don't remember seeing any.
>> I don't remember seeing any stars. He
doesn't remember anything. Okay. Did you
see how nervous they are? It's very
strange.
All right. And that's why even today
there are a lot of people who do not
believe
the moon landing happened. Okay. So,
we'll go over the theories as to why
later on, but but now let's switch focus
and let's look at 911.
All right. So, this is the buildings
coming down on 911. Watch how watch how
they come down. It's very strange. The
North Tower came crashing down.
a rumble.
>> So, this is strange because a plane hit
that building, right? Now, it's on fire.
It's very strange that the building
could come straight down like that. It's
almost like a demolition. I'm not saying
it's a demolition, but it looks kind of
strange. Okay. What's even stranger is
that there were two planes that hit the
twin towers that day. But there were
three buildings which came down. The
north tower, the south tower, and
building number seven, which was across
the street. Nothing hit that thing. It
came down. Okay. So, let's watch the
video.
It's on fire. Okay. But but whoa. It's
kind of strange.
Comes straight down.
Nothing hit that. Nothing. A plane did
not hit this thing. Okay.
And then of course there's another video
that's kind of strange, which is the
president of the United States, George
W. Bush
>> during the attacks.
>> He's president of the United States.
He's sitting in a classroom watching a
teacher teach.
>> That's kind of strange, guys. He's kind
of busy, right?
>> He spend the entire morning while the
attacks are happening just watching the
class being taught.
>> His positioning is weird because if
you're if you are a president, you
should be behind.
>> This is his assistant telling him
there's an attack.
Why is he being rushed out of that bu
that room and being put in a safe place?
Right.
>> Okay.
>> He's just he's just sitting there.
>> America's being attacked and he's just
sitting around with kids.
Mr.
>> President
York.
>> Thank you all. Step out.
>> Okay. So, a reporter is asking him, "Mr.
president, do you know that America's
being attacked right now? And he's like,
we'll talk about it later. He's not
worried.
He No, at this point, no one knows who's
attacking America. No one knows how
large the attack is. As president of
United States, he should be rushed
immediately to a safe location.
And he's not worried. He's like, "We'll
talk about later."
very very strange. Okay. And that's why
even today people are suspicious about
what happened.
Okay guys, so having seen the videos,
let's go over
what happened. Okay.
Okay.
So,
um, let's talk about
the JFK assassination. On November 22nd,
1963,
JFK was assassinated.
And Lyndon B. Johnson, new president, he
organizes a commission called the Warren
Commission to investigate what happened.
And they produced this huge huge report
thousand of pages and the report says
that
only one person was involved Lee Harvey
Oswald
and he was able to kill the president of
United States because of his common
sympathies and that's it. Okay.
There are certain problems though. Okay.
So, this is the president of United
States and he's in Dallas touring
um
uh Dallas.
I want to point something strange about
this picture. Okay, you see how in the
front JFK is in the front, but all the
security is behind him.
That makes no sense. What's the point of
security if the security is all behind
him, right? Because if someone rushes
and attacks him, they're too far behind,
right? Also, you see how the sold the
the the the bodyguards and the police
officers are to the side. Well, that's
to prevent snipers, right? So, my
question then is why is this car behind
structuring a way to protect the people
inside, but the carrying JFK, it doesn't
have any bodyguards?
>> That's kind of strange.
All right.
Um, this is the location,
the map of the motorcade. So, JFK, he's
streaming down and then he when he gets
into the spot, Leo Hareld is able to
take three shots at him and kill and
kill him at the spot. So, so Leo Oswald
takes three shots and kills JFK. But as
you can see, the problem with location
is there actually lots of places where
you can take a shot at the president
because he's in an open car
>> with no security.
And there were a lot of witnesses who
believe
that there were other shooters as well,
at least one more shooter.
>> And they heard the shot from other
places. Many of these witnesses, almost
30 of them were all killed or died. They
die mysteriously soon afterwards.
That's very strange.
Um this is the manora. Okay, which is a
uh holy candle in the Judeaic tradition.
You you see how the shape is very
similar to
this plaza called the Alia Plaza. What's
also interesting about the Ala Plaza is
it was a site of the first Freemason
large temple in Texas. Okay. So there's
there are these religious significance
to this place. It was almost like they
picked this place for a ritual
sacrifice.
Okay. So we'll talk about the Freemasons
later on because they're very important.
The Freemasons are the ones who uh some
say control America.
Okay.
Um,
Leo Harold fired three bullets and
there's one bullet which hit JFK, but
it's called a magic bullet because it
was also able to ricochet off JFK and
hit Governor Connelly who was also
sitting in the car as well.
>> Okay. So, they insisted that there was
only one shooter. He fired three shots
and one bullet was able to injure
everyone because the bullet was a magic
bullet that was in the official Warren
Commission.
Okay,
so Leo Harvey Osweld, he's he's been
arrested and he's been charged with
killing the president.
This is Leo Harvey Osweld when he's
going to court. He is ambushed by a man
named Jack Rubin. Do you see how close
shot gets and shoots Leha Roswell point
blank?
Okay, now this is a strange
picture because first of all, how did
Leo sorry, how did Jack Ruby get so
close? There was no security. Second of
all, you see how Leo Harold, he's being
held in held in place by two police
officers who are much bigger than him,
right? So, it's very hard for Osworld to
dodge the bullet. Okay, that's number
two. Number three is do you see his
reaction? He is a trained police officer
and he looks scared. He looks confused.
>> If you are a police officer and someone
comes at you menacing, right? You know
to push him away or draw your gun. But
you see how he just freezes.
>> That goes against his training. That's
very strange. Okay, I'm not saying that
this is a conspiracy, but I'm just
saying how this doesn't really add up.
There are lots of questions that are
raised by this. Also,
um
JFK has a brother, Robert F. Kennedy,
and in 1968, Robert F. Kennedy runs for
president, and it seems as though he's
about to win the Democratic nomination,
and then he gets killed, too.
And again, the question is how did this
happen? And it's a mystery how this man
named Sirhan Sirhan and he does not look
like a killer. Okay. Lehar Rosa does not
look like a killer. He does not look
like a killer either. Okay. But they
charge him with a crime and he's still
in prison. Even today, he's saying, "I
didn't do it." Okay.
All right.
So, now let's look at 911.
And as you can see from some of the
video footage,
it's very suspicious what happened.
There's other things that are suspicious
about what happened. First of all, a
month after the Twin Towers came down,
all that concrete and steel were shipped
to China.
>> Huh?
>> Yes, the Twin Towers, the debris is now
in China being put in other skyscrapers.
Who knows? Okay, but that's kind of
strange because you would obviously want
to run an investigation
before you ship that thing off. But they
did not do the investigation. They
shipped that debris to China right away.
That's the first thing. Second thing is
that never in the history of humanity
has a fire brought down a skyscraper.
Never before and never afterwards.
Investigators explained that what
happened was that the jet hit the uh
skyscraper and then because of the
explosion, because of the gas, the steel
frame start to melt. Okay? And then when
the top melt, it start to melt the the
um bottom one and the bottom one and the
bottom one. And and this is what we call
a pancake theory. Never in human history
has this happened before except with the
three buildings on 911. Okay. And the
third Yeah. And then two planes brought
down three buildings. The last thing is
that the plane the explosion was so
intense that no bodies were recovered,
no luggage was recovered, but we found
their passports.
Okay, we found their passports.
Uh these are the 19 hijackers who were
who the government decided was solely
responsible for the attacks. They had no
help.
They had no government help. They just
acted by themselves and they got really
lucky. Okay, luckiest people on the
planet. As you can see, this is their
passport that was found on a plane
wreckage. Didn't find any bodies. Didn't
find any luggage, but we found the
passport. So, we know for sure that it
was a terrorist and no one else.
This is a boarding pass.
Okay.
Found in the debris of the Twin Towers.
Pretty lucky. But this is conclusive
proof that the terrorists were
responsible and no one else.
Okay. Some more strange things about
911.
First of all, um we have a document
dated to 1962, a document called
Operation Northwoods. And the plan is
for the government to hijack civilian
aircraft planes and then blame it on
Cuba so that the United States can
declare war on Cuba.
Also,
um, 6 months before 911,
Fox, a television station in the United
States, they aired a television show
called The Lone Gunman. Okay? And the
and the
um plot is this. The government
pretends to be terrorists who hijack a
plane and crash it into
the World Trade Center so they can blame
it on terrorists so they can start all
these wars in the Middle East. What's
amazing about the show is that the plane
is not being controlled by terrorists.
It's being remote controlled
by government operatives.
So it sounds almost like exactly like
what happened on 911
6 months before 911 happened. That's
very strange. Okay, it gets stranger.
This is this man is named Larry
Silverstein and he is both the dumbest
and the luckiest businessman in the
world. He's the stupidest businessman in
the world because six weeks before 911,
he buys the lease to the World Trade
Center.
Okay? Why is that stupid? Because
the World Trade Center has asbestos and
like a dangerous chemical. So, they had
to
clean or remove the asbestos. The
problem is the cost of rem of reming all
that esbestos would have been more than
the value of the twin towers. That's
kind of stupid. Okay. Why would you
lease the twin towers knowing that you
you have to put all this money into
renovation which would bankrupt you.
>> Also, what's stupid is
to have the lease, you're required to
have insurance.
Okay? And so the insurance company says
we value the World Trade Center at $ 1.5
billion. Okay. And Larry Silver, no,
it's not $1.5 billion. They are worth
$3.5 billion. So he is asking to pay
more insurance than he needed to. That's
kind of stupid.
But again, he's the luckiest man in the
world because none of it happens. And
guess what? He can now claim that two
towers were struck and therefore he
should get twice as much as 3.55
million. He should get 7 billion.
And he sued they went to court and he
got 4.55 billion. Okay. He's also lucky
because he's he's a workaholic. He never
misses work. But that day because of a
dermatology appointment, he had to miss
work. He wasn't there when 911 happened.
The luckiest man in the world. Okay. So
this teaches us that in life, do not be
um
smart. Just be lucky. Okay, that's all
you need. All right. Now, I know all
this sounds suspicious,
but there are lots of reasons why we
should just believe the government.
Okay? Why we should believe the United
States government is telling us the
truth that 911 was
um done just by 15 terrorists operating
alone running help that JFK was killed
by one lone gunman named Lee Harvey
Oswald that the moon landing was
actually real. Okay, so let's go over
the reasons why we should never ever
believe conspiracy theories. Okay, the
first reason of course is the government
would never lie to us. Okay, that's the
first reason. It's probably the best
reason. Second reason is well the
government is too stupid to do anything
like this. Okay, they're incompetent.
Okay, the third reason is
why is there so much evidence
that there's a conspiracy theory, right?
If the government is so powerful, if
they're capable of like doing these
conspiracies, surely they can cover it
up as well. Why is it on 911 we have all
this footage?
Why is it that we have uh the passports?
Why is it that we have like this TV
show? Why is there so much evidence?
That makes no sense,
right? So, the fact that there's so much
evidence suggests to us that
the government is not involved. Okay?
because the government is so powerful
that it can just cover everything up,
right? Another thing is
NASA has 400,000 people working on the
space program, right?
Why has anyone come forward and
confessed? Why has anyone told the
truth? That's kind of strange. So the
fact that so many people were involved
but no one has come out and told us what
happened means that
um the government was telling the truth.
Okay, does that make sense? It's very
hard to keep 4,000 people quiet. Okay,
someone might have told a friend or a
family member or just might have gotten
drunk and then you know done a YouTube
video. Who knows? Okay, but it's very
hard to keep 400,000 people under wraps.
Um JFK, why not have to kill him in
public? Why not just make it a private
thing? You know, just give him give him
some poison, he dies. No one knows. Why
make it into a spectacle?
Okay. So, another reason to doubt um
conspiracy theory. Okay.
And the last thing is
if the government
was really involved, they would not
allow us to discuss this, right? They
wouldn't allow me to find this video
online. They could just cover it all up.
Right? All all these videos I've shown
you are online.
So, this tells us the government doesn't
have anything to fear.
Right? Okay. So, we're in a strange
situation where we can either believe
the government is telling us the truth,
but then we have all this evidence to
suggest that they're not telling us the
truth, or we can believe that they did
this,
but we all what we also have to believe
is that they did this and they want us
to know that they did this and they want
us to talk about these conspiracy
theories.
Okay, that's kind of strange.
Well, it turns out we have an
explanation for this. It's called
revelation of method. The idea is that
those who engage in evil must tell you
that they are engaging in evil. The
theory is that those who do conspiracies
must tell you they're doing
conspiracies. And there are three
reasons why. Okay, so let's go over
them. The first reason is the idea of
learn helplessness. And so the idea is
okay let's just say that we everyone
knows that they did this right we get
angry we write emails we make YouTube
videos then what
nothing
>> right so the idea of learn helplessness
is like the more angry you get the more
helpless you feel and therefore the more
obedient you become okay that's the
first reason second reason is the idea
of karmic responsibility and the idea is
that the people in power are extremely
super or excuse me superstitious.
They believe that when they die, God
will judge them. Okay, so we're all dead
and God says to the government, "Hey,
why did you do all this evil stuff?" And
the government says, "No, no, no. I did
not act alone. Everyone participated."
Why? Because I told them what I was
doing. They didn't stop me. They didn't
raise any concerns. They didn't protest.
Therefore, they are complicit. Okay. So,
another way of saying this is
if you just look at 911, if you just
look at the moon landing, you just look
at JFK, the evidence is so overwhelming
that if you still believe the
government, it's not because you are
ignorant or stupid. It's because you are
complicit. It's because you are
involved. Therefore, you share the
guilt. Therefore, the karma is spread to
everyone. Okay, that's the logic, right?
The third reason is attention capture.
These events are set up in a way so that
they will be remembered forever. Okay?
So, everyone remembers where they were,
what they were doing, who they were with
on 911
when JFK was assassinated during the
moon landing. Okay? So you probably were
not in United States. You might have
been in China. You might have been tun
uh floor uh Tunisia. You might have been
in South Africa. It doesn't matter.
Okay? You could have you could have been
on the moon. Okay? But you still
remember what you were doing on 911
because it's edged into your
consciousness. And that's the point. The
point is to control people by
controlling people how by controlling
how people perceive reality. How okay?
Because then you have the power of God.
Okay, so these are three ma major
reasons why um they will do this evil
but they will tell you they did this
evil and they want they want you to
discuss and continue to discuss why they
do this evil. Okay, so even today people
are still writing books about JFK.
People are still writing books about the
moonlighting. It's allowed because it's
attention capture. Okay, it's like the
idea of top of mind. So if you're a
company, you don't care about bad
publicity. All publicity is good because
it's top of mind, right? So if you are
hungry and you want to go out for lunch,
what's the first thing that um you want
to eat? It's the first thing that comes
to mind,
>> right? So maybe pizza or hamburger.
Okay, that's the idea of branding. So
that's what they're doing here. They're
trying to control your reality through
these events.
Okay, does that make sense, guys?
>> Okay, any questions?
All right. Now, what I want to do is
look at a question. Okay. Let's look at
certain questions.
Why is this happening?
All right. So, let's look at
JFK
and 911 and the moon landing.
What are common characteristics about
these three events? Okay, the first
thing of course is that they are
spectacles.
You can say that they are rituals.
A lot of care, a lot of attention was
put into preparing these rituals. So for
example, the JFK assassination, look at
the location, right?
Look at the
um choreography.
Okay, they did it purposely in front of
people but also in front of cameras so
that it'll be remembered forever. Okay,
the moon landing as well, 911 as well.
Okay.
Um that's the first thing. Second thing
is the idea of numerology.
So when you look at these events, what
you'll find is that numerology is very
important. Okay. Okay, it's a very
simple concept to understand. So, for
example, let's just say you want to get
married, right? Well, you want to pick
an auspicious date. So, maybe August
8th, 88, right? Or June 6, an auspicious
date because that will give your wedding
the most chances to prosper. You also
want to pick pick a nice location fun,
>> right? Same thing with with with this
idea. Okay, so look at the let's look at
the numerology. JFK
was November 22nd, 1963. 11:22
1963.
The moon landing
was 1969.
And then 911 was of course 911. Pretty
easy to remember, right? Okay. Now,
what's interesting is that these are all
triangular numbers. Okay. What are
triang numbers? 1369.
Right. 1369.
1963.
1969.
Okay. Also, the number 33
is very very important.
Okay. Number 33 is almost like a magic
number to these people. Okay. And so
like what what what we what we believe
is that it's secret societies that are
responsible for these events.
Okay. Uh mainly the three masons but
there are others as well. Okay. I I'll
I'll discuss later. Number 33 is
important. Okay. So look at this. 11 +
22 is what? 33.
Okay guys
um one one one. Okay. You see how nice
this number is? 33 is also two triangles
right? What happens when you put two
triangles together? you get the star of
David which is the flag of Israel.
Okay. So number 33 is a very special
number
for secret societies. All right. Here's
something that's that's really also
really interesting. How about number 33?
If you look at the world map, okay, the
equator.
If you go north
33 degrees, you get a lot of places.
Okay. The first place you get is uh in
Mesopotamia, Iraq. It's where the tiger
is and Euphrates. These are two rivers.
This is where they meet. Okay. Why is
this important? Because the meet this
meeting place is what we considered the
birth of civilization. It's a crit of
civilization.
Over here is Baghdad.
Baghdad was the capital of the Islamic u
golden age. The Islamic caliphate. Okay.
Historical city. Over here is Damascus,
one of the oldest cities in the world.
Over here, of course, is Jerusalem, the
holiest city for both the Christians and
for the Jews.
Okay?
You keep on going over here to America.
This is Dallas. Why is Dallas important?
Because that's where JFK was
assassinated.
>> But you keep on going, and this is like
interesting. You go to New Mexico and
you get to the Trinity test site. This
is um where the atomic bomb was
detonated. Okay.
You go over here 33 degrees in Japan. Do
you know what city is 33 degrees north
in Japan?
>> You mean not Tokyo? There are two
cities, Hiroshima and Nakasaki.
>> Why are they important?
Okay, these are the two places where the
atomic bomb was dropped. Okay, think
about that. 33 north in New Mexico is
where they tested the atom bomb and then
Hiroshima Nagasaki 33 33 north is where
they dropped the two atomic bombs.
Okay. All right. So, why is this
important? Because if you're a secret
society,
what makes secret society important is
the mythology or the story that they
tell about their purpose. Okay. Now,
it's easy to understand
here why 33 degrees is important. Okay.
Because 33 degrees, you're not too hot
because you're away from the equator,
but you're not too cold. Okay? So, you
can farm. That's why all these major
cities including Baghdad, Damascus,
Jerusalem are situated 33 degrees north.
Okay. Also a place called Harappa. Okay,
which is the Indis Valley civilization
is also 33 degrees north. So a lot of
major cities are situated in this
latitude. So that makes sense. Okay,
this is the old world.
What's the old world? The old world is
obey God.
Okay, that's the old world. Now we go to
the new world. Okay. What makes the new
new world different? Well, when America
was founded, there was a religion called
theism.
And theism, the belief is that God
created the universe, but then he went
away. So, the universe is what we make
of it. Okay? So, now we can be we are
God.
And this is the grand secret of these
secret societies.
They exist in order to do what God could
not do or what God can do to replace
God. So what is it that God does? Well,
what the first God does is he changes
matter. Changes matter. Second thing is
he can kill other gods.
The third thing is he he can create
life.
All right. What does change matter mean?
It means the nuclear bomb.
>> Right? the nuclear bomb. So what what
what does kill the gods mean? It means
you can kill
president of United States JFK who is
considered a prince.
Okay. And what does create life? It
means you create artificial intelligence
which is the last step.
Okay. So this is part of the mythology.
The old world is being replaced by the
new world. Okay. Now, if you're able to
do all three things, now you're able to
bring heaven to earth. Now, you're able
to declare yourself God. And for that,
what you need is a world government. And
to show that you are truly in power,
what you do is you combine the old world
and the new world together by making
Jerusalem
your world capital.
Okay? So towards the end of semester I
will tell I I will show you what the
grand plan is for Jerusalem. But for now
what you need to understand is that
right now in Jerusalem there's something
called the alaxac mosque
which is the third holiest site in the
Islamic tradition. It is the place where
Muhammad ascended to heaven. They plan
to destroy the alac mos to rebuild the
temple of Solomon called the third
temple.
Okay, this will start World War II.
Okay, because the Muslims will get angry
at this and they will come invade Israel
and that's the purpose. So there's a
grand plan to create the world
government
by initiating World War II.
Okay.
So
uh we'll be discussing this later on in
the semester.
Now I want to discuss
how secret societies are able to wield
so much power. Okay, first of all, how
is it that they're able to keep everyone
quiet,
right? How are they able to maintain
their secrets? And then how are they
able to
exert power? Okay.
All right. So the first thing you need
to understand about secret societies is
that there are different layers
to secret society. Okay. So in Scottish
right Freemasonry there are 33 grades.
30 33 grades. So you start at one and
then you slowly climb. Okay. Some people
can skip and at each different grade
you're taught different secrets or
understanding of the world. So maybe
here here here you have four grades.
Okay.
In the bottom grade, all you're taught
is just to be a good person, to do good
works, to do charity, to be kind. That's
all you're taught. Okay.
But as you as you move up, you're taught
something else, which is
um we can do God's work.
Okay? God has given us a mission. We
must do God's work.
Okay? And up here is we don't need God.
Okay? The higher you climb, the more
secrets you're told. And then the as you
move up further, you're taught we don't
need God. Okay? So guys, I'm not part of
a secret society. I'm just making this
up. Okay? I'm just showing you how they
might work. I'm just spec speculating.
The last layer is
we can be God by killing God.
Do you understand? So it's almost like
school, right? In primary school, you
work hard, you learn a lot. You go to
high school, in high school, they teach
you everything you learn in primary
school is wrong. Let us teach you new
knowledge. You you work hard, you learn
all this new knowledge. You go to
university, the professors there are
like everything you learn in high school
is wrong, so let's learn something new.
Okay? And then you go to to graduate
school and you're taught everything you
learn university is wrong. Okay. So
that's how these secret societies work.
So this the word we use is
carartmentalized.
So it's a need to know.
Okay. Does that make sense? You are only
taught what you need to know at your
grade.
Okay. And as you can see the secrets get
worse and worse as you climb.
So how do you maintain secrecy in the
system? Okay. So there are
two major mechanisms. Okay. The first
major mechanism
is incentives.
Incentives. Sorry. Incentives. The idea
here is the higher you climb, the more
power you have.
>> Okay?
So these people in the middle,
all they care about is maintaining a
privilege.
>> Okay? So that's so does that make sense?
Incentives. Okay. The higher you climb,
the more invested you are.
>> Therefore, you want to believe the lie.
Then
there's blackmail.
So if you really want to climb to the
top, you have to reveal your secrets
too. So you can be blackmailed.
>> Okay? And we talked about this, right?
The idea of transgression.
If you really want to climb to the top,
you have to commit crimes with other
people. So therefore, you can never
betray other people.
>> Okay?
And
the last thing that helps the system is
confirmation bias. And the idea of
confirmation bias is you just want to
believe what you want to believe. Okay?
People don't want to believe the
government lies to them. People want to
believe the government tells the truth.
So
we like to live in a fantasy world.
Okay? So this is what keeps the system
intact.
Okay? So this is how secret societies
keep their secrets. Does that make
sense? Okay. Now the question then is
how is it that they're able to to wield
power? And the answer is this structure
is perfect for a bureaucracy. Last
before we talked about bureaucracies,
right? How as society matures it becomes
more bureaucratic. Well, the problem is
that bureaucracies
become topheavy.
Too many managers also the idea of
silos. So each department does its own
thing. Okay. And as I said also
bureaucrats don't want to do any work.
>> So imagine
if your secret society how much you can
benefit from the system, right? because
you want to work because you want to
achieve your vision and you're able to
work with other people secretly.
Therefore, you're able to promote each
other into position of power and because
these departments are all siloed off.
They're all independent. You're able to
control the entire bureaucracy because
you're able to coordinate but they're
not.
>> Okay, does that make sense? So what we
learn is that in history as societies
become much more mature, as they become
much more bureaucratic, secret societies
have much more power and in and today we
are living in a heavily bureaucratic
world and therefore the secret societies
have more and more power. Okay?
>> And um
does that make sense? The other thing
that we need to remember is that
um there are thousands and thousands of
secret societies. Okay. So, so let's
name some of them. The Freemasons,
the Jesuits,
uh the Mormons,
the Frankus. Okay, lots and lots. Okay,
we'll we'll we'll go over each one later
on the semester. What you need to
remember is that at this stage in
development when society's bureaucratic
when they become parasites on the
bureaucracy they are incentivized to
work together to achieve their vision.
Okay. But once they create the world
government then they will fight each
other but at this point in their
development they will work and actively
collaborate together. Okay. So 911, JFK,
Moonlanding, they were all working
together.
Okay. So we'll be setting this more as
the semester progresses.
All right. So um let's conclude.
Sorry.
Okay. Okay, let's let let's let's let's
conclude. Okay,
sorry I'm uh
Okay, so let's talk about the atomic
bomb. This is Henry Henry Truman. Okay,
Henry Truman is the 33rd president of
the United States, number 33, right?
He's also a 33rd degree Freemason, which
is the highest Freemason. Okay, why is
it important? Because he's the one who
ordered the dropping of the atomic bombs
on Hiroshima and Nagasaki.
Now, this is controversial because at
this point, America didn't have to bomb
n have to nuke Japan. Why? Because
America was firebombing Tokyo. You can
see the damage, right? In Tokyo, all the
houses are wooden. Guess what? If you
drop firebombs on these houses,
everything burns. So, America was just
burning Japan to death. They didn't have
to drop the nuclear bombs.
Okay, you can see the devastation. Okay,
this is Tokyo. They burned everything
down.
There was talk that if America launched
a land invasion of Japan, lots of people
would have died. But you didn't have to
invade Japan because you were just
bombing Japan to to ashes. So why did
they drop the bomb? Well, the other
argument is that they dropped the bomb
to scare the Soviet Union,
but that only encouraged the Soviet
Union get to get their own bomb, right?
So you have to ask yourself why do they
do this? And if you go back to the 33
degree story, okay, which is just
explained, it gives you an explanation.
I'm not saying it's right, but it offers
you a possibility.
Okay?
Okay. So as you can see um all these
major cities including Babylon,
including uh Baghdad, Damascus,
um
Hiroshima
are all part of 33 degree latitude.
Okay, guess what guys? A lot of famous
athletes wear number 33 and they are
Freemasons. Okay, so this is Scotty
Pippen and and and Shaquille O'Neal. We
know they are Freemasons. Larry Bird and
Kareem Adul Jabbar also wear number 33.
Okay.
Um 33 is important. Jesus died when he
was 33 years old. The word God, Elohim,
appears 33 times in Genesis. King David
reigned for 33 years. The Vic Pathalon.
Hinduism has 33 dietes. Human spine has
33 bones. Okay. So number 33 appears
over and over. So these societies see
number 33 as a magic magic number.
Um, the moon landing.
Okay, I'm not saying the moon landing
was faked, but there's an argument that
it is impossible for humans to leave
something called the Van Allen belt.
Okay, the Van Allen belt is this
electromagnetic field that protects us
from cosmic radiation. So that the belts
themselves have heavy radiation. So if
you go into it, you die. But also, if
you leave the Van Island belts, there's
nothing to protect you from cosmic
radiation. So you could die as well. So
some scientists actually believe that
it's impossible to leave
Earth. Okay, we'll just die.
I don't know how they were able to do
this. And um as you may know, right now
a lot of countries, America, China are
trying to get back to the moon. They're
having a really hard time. Okay, they're
having a hard time because NASA lost all
the technology, lost all the footage,
lost all the data. Oops.
Oh well. Okay.
So, so um how was NASA able to keep this
secret? Well, guess what? A lot of their
most important people were Freemasons.
Okay. This is Boss Boss Uldren, one of
the free astronauts. He was a Freemason.
Okay.
Um John Glenn, the first American to
orbit the Earth, was a Freemason, 33
degree Mason. Okay.
Um all as was James Webb, one one of the
first NASA administrators, James Webb.
Um Kenneth K.
Um so these people are embedded
throughout the bureaucracy and because
they're able to coordinate that complete
control of the bureaucracy. Does that
make sense? So it doesn't matter who's
at the top. What matters is which
barecross are able to work together to
achieve their vision.
This is um Warner von Brown and he was
one of the first NASA leaders and he's a
German. He was actually a Nazi who was
brought over after World War II to help
America build its space program. Okay.
Um and he had a he had a friend or a
colleague named Carol Rosen. And we
don't know if this is true. Okay. But
what Carol Wilson tells us is that when
von Braun died, he told us that America,
the American government was first and
foremost concerned about spending
weapons, sorry, spending money on space
weapons. Okay. And what and to do this,
what America will do is continue to
manufacture threats to justify all the
spending on weaponry. Okay. And then she
lists the different threats. First, they
will use Russians. Okay. the Russians.
We have to defeat the Russians in the
space race. Then they'll be like, "You
know what? Terrorists, okay, 911,
then third world countries, the craziest
like North Korea. Okay, Iran. And then
an asteroid. We we need we need space
weapons to protect the earth from
asteroids. And then the last thing is a
fake alien invasion." Okay,
>> aliens.
Okay, does that make sense? Okay. So,
we'll talk about this later towards the
end end of the semester about a fake
alien invasion. Okay. That's part of the
plan and they've been seing this for a
long time. So, um I'll conclude by
talking about different possibilities.
You don't have to believe me. Okay? In
fact, there are I think five different
possibilities as to what happened. Okay.
The footage looks fake. So, how to
explain this? Well, the first
explanation is
it's real footage and we should we
should just believe the government.
Okay. But we we also need to believe
that they lost all the footage, lost all
the technology, lost all the data. Okay,
that's possibly number one. Just believe
what the government tells you. Possibly
number two is America went to the moon,
but the astronauts discovered too many
secrets on the moon. Like there are
space aliens on the moon, they can't
tell us. So they create this fake
footage. Okay, that's second
possibility. Third possibility is
America went to the moon, but because of
the lighting, because of the difficulty
of filming, they couldn't actually take
any footage. So they made it up to
please the American people. Okay. Um the
fourth possibility is America went to
the moon. Um but they NASA decided to
create this fake footage to fool the
Soviets, right? Because if it's real
footage, the first Soviets might be able
to copy the technology. So we should
just fake this thing and make fun of the
Soviets. Okay, let's fool the Soviets so
they couldn't so the Soviets cannot
reverse engineer the success. Okay,
that's also a possibility,
>> right? And the last possibility of
course is America didn't go to the moon.
>> And it's entirely your choice which
possibility to believe. Okay? I'm just
proposing different possibilities out
there.
So how can we know the truth? Well,
we can use game theory to logically
deduce what happened. Okay. So let's use
game theory.
All right. So, we know that NASA's
Apollo program cost $26 billion between
1960 and 1973. That's almost $20 billion
today. They spent all this money. They
need to produce a result, right? This is
almost like 4% of all government
spending in America. That's a lot of
money.
Also, you don't know this, but by 1969,
America was falling apart for three
reasons. First of all, America was
fighting this pointless and hopeless war
called Vietnam. Tens of thousands of
Americans were dying for no reason.
Hundreds of thousands of young Americans
were protesting on the streets. America,
the American dream seem to be dying.
Okay, that's the first problem. Second
problem is that the Soviets were
destroying the Americans in the space
race. The Soviets were the first to send
an animal to space, the first to send a
man to space, the first to orbit
um the Earth, the first to walk in
space, the first send a lun lunar modu
module to the moon. So it seemed as
though commis were superior to
capitalism. It seemed as though the
Soviet system was better than the
American system. Okay, there's a real
fear that the Soviets would get to the
moon first. Okay. And also the last
thing is remember in 1963 JFK was
killed. JFK was the prince, the king. So
that put Americans in a very bad mood.
But but then later on other prominent
Americans like uh Robert F. Kennedy and
Martin Luther King, they all killed as
well. So 1969, America was divided, was
falling apart. People felt hopeless,
right? So what this means is that if
America sent a mission to the moon and
all the astronauts died or they didn't
get there, America would have been
broken. Okay? People would have been
depressed. And so according to game
theory,
America could not afford to take the
risk of sending people to the moon. If
they died, if it failed, America would
have looked like idiots.
Okay? But of course, there's always a
counterargument. The counterargument is,
okay, this makes sense, but why did the
Soviets
call out the Americans and said, you
guys fake this,
right?
>> What the America and soviet Union were
in competition with with each other.
Everyone believed America went to the
moon, but there's a lot of evidence
suggest that it America didn't go to the
moon. So why why did the Soviets tell
the world? Okay, that I can't answer for
you.
>> All right, so I just leave you with this
thought.
Okay, but what I believe is with the
next two years the truth will slowly
start to come out and you will see for
yourself what really happened. So this
class is not meant to tell you what
happened. This class is just meant to
give you different possibilities and
give you tools
to understand or figure out for yourself
what might have happened. Okay.
>> All right. So, any questions before we
conclude?
Um, as we said, uh, the secret society
might have a, um, might fighting with
the governments, but why don't they send
their part of their people into the
governments? Why don't they like work
together?
>> No, no, they are the government.
>> Oh, okay. Fine.
>> Yeah. Right. Because they because like
secret societies cannot exist outside of
bureaucracies,
>> right? They have power because they're
able to coordinate within the
bureaucracy in a way that other
organizations cannot.
Right?
>> So only when the broadcast has reached a
certain maturity, a certain size can
secretist have true power.
>> Right.
So secret societies are the ones who
control the government basically.
>> Yeah. Any other questions?
>> Okay. Great guys. So we'll continue this
next class, next week. Okay. All right.